Cuomo and Jenna have been given a second
chance by the judges and can join the
other safe couples my friend we have to
say goodbye to you for a while a tough
night tonight you guys going home Lamar
just tell me how you're feeling tomorrow
work out
I mean Lia was a guest judge and she was
crying over the hard work that you've
done what did that mean to see both her
and Peeta gets here you over you tonight
means a lot especially when I seen Peter
crying my sister here but I would like
to move on but since it didn't happen
now I can just move on and other things
a mother what do you plan to do public
speaking tell people my story and
hopefully I can change laughs or that I
mean Peeta you were talking about how
people aren't realizing how difficult
this is for Lamar Lamar can you speak to
that a little bit has this been a lot
harder for you than people knew
physically yeah
not physically I just think from my
accident my cognitive like memory like
suffered from that axe
so just from memorizing the dance
routine was difficult at times but I
felt like I got better every week it's
so crazy because I felt like this is my
best dance it's just tonight so you know
what means you get teary over this you
get to see like a one-minute package
before we dance every week and so much
work and hours go in behind it that
people don't really get to see it's
emotional because I see him every day
I'm with him for for at least four hours
five hours a day and to know like the
work that he's put in behind it even to
just get you know a couple of steps and
how hard sometimes that is it was just I
was just really super proud of him yeah
yeah Lamar what do you kind of want
people to know from what you've been
through what to take away from never
quit you have to like beat me down and
kick me out but I'll never quit I felt
like this is going to help me
and my public speaking was doing
something now not used to doing almost
afraid to do it was cool to see your
kids show up and and they said you know
our dad almost died and now he's here
with us how emotional was that for you
to watch to hear them say that it's
always emotional when we talk about that
but it's life and it happened and now I
can just get better and learn you were
such an inspiration thank you Peter will
we see you back on dancing again yes you
probably see me every week now I just
the same I'll be here dancing around him
[Applause]
[Music]